our National Space Council will
re-energize the pioneering spirit of
America in space and it will ensure that
America never again loses our lead in
space exploration innovation and
technology that was Vice President Mike
Pence introducing NASA's newest class of
astronauts yesterday they could take
part in missions abroad aboard
commercially built spacecraft from
private companies like SpaceX NASA is
counting on SpaceX to bring cargo and
eventually astronauts to the
International Space Station
SpaceX relies on NASA contracts and its
launch pad now well borkus at Kennedy
Space Center in Florida shows how this
cooperation could turn into competition
complete with a Hollywood soundtrack
NASA for years has promoted plans to
send humans into deep space but it's
Space Launch System won't be ready to
bring humans around the moon until at
least 2021 so it came as a surprise to
NASA when SpaceX founder Elon Musk held
a conference call this is a tribute
thanks super inspiration announcing
plans to use a powerful rocket that
hasn't yet flown to sling private
tourists around the moon next year an
ambitious timeline according to Maryland
did mark who represents some of space
axis competitors through the Coalition
for deep space exploration if you're
putting all the schedule pressure on
you're automatically creating an
environment where you are operating at
higher risk because you have to meet the
deadlines do you see that happening
currently I'm concerned about the 2018
guy deadline for for SpaceX the company
is already busy launching commercial
satellites while working on a NASA
contract to launch astronauts to the
International Space Station and liftoff
nASA has relied on Russia for rides to
space ever since its shuttle program
ended in 2011 not anything against the
Russians but it would be good to have
Americans that are able to move back and
forth now from earth to space using our
own vehicles the bigger prize is Mars
both NASA and SpaceX are working
separately on plans to get to the Red
Planet do you see any scenario where
NASA and these come
these might be stepping on each other's
toes at all well yes people are have to
relearn the dance steps right Charles
Miller is president of next-gen space he
advised president Trump's NASA
transition team to embrace competition
between traditional aerospace
contractors and companies like SpaceX it
seems to have worked
president Trump's proposed budget for
NASA in 2018 increases cooperation with
industry it's my belief that the human
spaceflight endeavor of NASA will
collapse unless we get more innovation
from American free enterprise we've been
involved into that new way of business
for a while acting administrator Robert
Lightfoot appeared to agree we will big
companies from small companies won't
everybody to kind of help us do this
this journeys hard yet some basic
differences still have to be resolved a
NASA safety group raised concerns about
SpaceX's plans to fuel its rockets with
humans on board after this explosion
while fueling an unmanned rocket last
year
Maryland Dittmar worries any disaster
involving SpaceX could have larger
implications for the future of space
exploration might people extrapolate
from that well this is so dangerous
nobody should be doing it is there that
danger I think there is that danger
I would hope not you know I would hope
that people wouldn't go down that road
but but I do worry about it SpaceX would
not comment for this story but Elon Musk
has defended the fueling process and
said the company's doing everything it
can to minimize the risks later this
year's SpaceX is planning to test a
larger version of its Falcon rocket the
one that will eventually carry tourists
going around the moon for CBS this
morning I'm Manuel Bojorquez at Kennedy
Space Center